affordable housing continues to be just
a crisis in southern nevada with the
average home price sitting above four
hundred thousand dollars but a new
project in the works hopes to make the
dream of home ownership a reality for
some low-income families arko mana is
live in the studio tonight to break down
some of the details for us
denise the area we're talking about is
in the far southwest valley off of
cactus between buffalo and rainbow and
more than 100 homes are expected to be
built on this land and the idea is that
low income families will be able to
specifically purchase them
it's been difficult to find housing
ernie rivas is a single father of two
for five months he's lived at the manor
suites a weekly just south of the las
vegas strip he's looking for a home but
the cost is too high they want you to
obviously make three sometimes four
times the amount of rent
and a lot of cases a lot of people in
vegas don't make that much experts say
it's because of more demand las vegas is
considered one of the highest most
expensive cities
in the united states that's why ernie is
thrilled a new affordable housing
project is in the works in the southwest
valley clark county commissioners voted
this week to give a local developer the
green light to build more than 100 homes
on these 15 acres of land near cactus
and buffalo all for lower income
families to buy i'd be the first in my
you know my immediate family to actually
own a home
and not only that but it would mean a
lot to my kids as well this will be the
first time we've done something like
this in clark county clark county
commissioner justin jones tells me home
ownership for lower income families can
also overcome other challenges if you're
a teacher a firefighter or somebody who
just wants to live in a nice community
send your kids to a nice school it's
really hard so we really wanted to
provide those working families with
another option ernie cannot wait it's an
opportunity for us to own a home and
you know take advantage of it
now the project is still in its early
stages commissioner jones tells me
what's next in the process is working
with the developer on the design plan
and collaborating with the blm on how
much the homes will cost because the blm
actually owns that land brian